Laura, I know that you love to cook.
And I actually just really quickly wanna ask you a question,
because I was saying it's not Prepon Kitchen,
it's Prep-On Kitchen.
Can you tell me the history of why that is the name?
Well, it's Prep-On Kitchen because I feel like,
if you prep your food in advance,
it's a lot easier to get homemade meals on the table.
And also for years,
people have always called me Laura Prep on.
(laughs)
So it's kind of like this beautiful mix of,
it helping you prep quickly
and also people messing up my name.
(laughs)
I love that.
All right, we wanna bring someone
who is a dear friend to the show,
and she is gonna teach us a recipe.
Because listen, we're talking about Mother's Day week.
And I mean, this woman is a mom and a grandmother
and we all fell in love with her
as brunchwithbabs on TikTok.
And her videos are deliciously addicting to watch.
So please welcome back, Babs.
(audience cheering)
I'm back, I'm Babs.
(laughs)
(audience cheering)
Hi, Babs.
I'm so happy to be here again.
So Babs, I want you to tell us,
and teach us a perfect Mother's Day brunch type of recipe.
What is this?
Okay, so this is a lovely frittata.
We're going to be making this today.
And frittatas have like an emotional connection with me
because my earliest memory of my mom in the kitchen,
coming from a first generation, Italian family
was making potatoes and eggs on a Friday.
And we call them afrittats.
So frittatas have come a long way.
Yeah.
And for Mother's Day, as again,
so versatile, you can use the vegetables your mom loves
or the protein or whatever,
but today we're making a bacon, rear, veggie frittata.
Okay Babs.
So yeah,
really great combination.
And we're cooking it all,
with Laura's beautiful Prep-On kitchenware,
which I'm so excited to feature.
So we're your students,
and we want you to teach us Babs, walk us through it.
All right, so here's what so far,
I think we fried five strips of bacon
and we set that aside, and we Premal that,
and we reserved two tablespoons of the bacon fat
and we blistered tomatoes, about a cup of cherry tomatoes.
And to that we added leaks and shiitake mushrooms.
And now girls, you're going to add to your skillet,
a cup of fresh baby spinach.
Oh, beautiful.
Then you add that.
And to that you're going to add a tablespoon of fresh thyme,
which is ready to go.
I love fresh herbs.
Yes.
As my mom says
fresh herbs makes everything fancy.
It does.
And then you also gonna return the crumbled bacon,
the cooked bacon back to your skillet.
Yes, please.
Okay.
So now we're gonna just drizzle it
with just a little olive oil,
just over the top so that when we make our frittata,
it's gonna come sliding right out,
because eventually that's going to come out of the skillet.
Yeah.
Skillet's also it's blue carbon steel.
So the more you use it,
it becomes more naturally non-stick.
Oh lovely.
So it's great for this frittata.
I have to say too,
one thing that I really now have come to care about
in pots and pans is how easy
and amazing it is that this is a very hot pan
and yet I can grab the sides.
Well done.
Right.
Thank you for that.
Thank you!
Okay, now what?
So now, we're gonna focus on the egg mixture.
So I think you have, like
I know you have 10 eggs already in there,
you're gonna crack two more.
It's a 12 egg frittata,
and-
Drew, toss your shells in the bag, it's for food scraps.
By the way, Laura,
please show us this because I'm obsessed.
Sorry Babs did not mean to interrupt us,
wanna make sure Drew throws her little food scraps
in the bag because this is also to help
with making your food prep easier.
All your food scraps just tossed right
in your bag and the later.
That's brilliant.
That's fabulous.
This is biodegradable and compostable.
All my work is get rid of it.
Perfect.
I don't mean to be hyperbolic,
but I never want to see a cutting board again,
without this, I'm sorry,
ever.
I'm gonna be using this cutting board,
from now on.
Thank you.
It is, with the automatic garbage bag.
What am I doing next time?
Now we're putting a quarter cup of,
you can use heavy cream,
you can use half and half or full fat milk
and that's going right into the eggs.
Okay.
And then a half a teaspoon of salt
and a half a teaspoon of pepper.
Now you can start whisking.
All right.
And just mix that whole thing.
And then we're gonna add the three quarter cup
of cheese to our egg mixture.
And you don't need to make the eggs frothy
just till everything kind of combined.
Don't overdo it.
I overdo everything Babs.
I do.
Moderation is hard.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm working out and my trainer Katrina
will be like, "Stop."
And I'm just like, "Mm mm mm."
I'm like a jack rabbit.
I need to be more like that.
Moderation is a delicate balance, you know?
I just, I think I'm just a little intense.
And then we're going to pour that
over our veggie bacon mixture.
Ooh.
So we're just gonna pour that on
and we're gonna let it set for a few seconds
until eventually we see a crust forming
around the edge of the skillet
and where the eggs meet the skillet.
And when you see that,
you're just gonna push the egg mixture into the center.
Much like you're making curds like scrambled eggs.
So I think now we could put it in the oven
at 450 for five minutes, and then after five minutes at 450.
In they go.
Thank you.
Then we're gonna take them out
and put them on your platter or your whatever
and you can serve them and don't they look yummy?
They look so beautiful.
Should we try it?
This is so good.
It is delicious.
You guys did an amazing job.
This is incredible.
Babs.
Oh, this was great.
I can't imagine having any Mother's Day celebration
without you.
Please keep celebrating what it's like to be a mom,
a woman, you know,
Grandma.
A human.
And Laura, I am just so thrilled to do this with you.
I'm so excited about Prep-On Kitchen.
I'm so thrilled and be sure to check out
Laura's culinary line Prep-On Kitchen,
launching on HSN, May 7th and Babs thank you.
Happy Mother's Day.
Thank you for having me.
(upbeat music)